Adolf Hitler was definitely a cult
leader they weren't saying Heil Germany
they were saying Heil Hitler the leader
of North Korea Kim is a cult leader if
Scientology had said to Tom Cruise in
the very beginning what they fully
believe I think he would have said God
you guys have got to screw loose have
you seen any overlap recently in
affiliation with political parties and
cult-like behavior well this episode is
sponsored by nordvpn if you followed the
show for a while then you've probably
heard me complain about how bad Canadian
Netflix is it was bad as a teenager it
was it was annoying to go to America and
see how good Netflix was a few Americans
don't know is bad I mean Netflix has
been bad recently in America too I
suppose but at least it has variety here
I used nordvpn to watch the best shows
on Netflix and online anywhere in the
world from Canada now that I live in
Miami I don't use nordvpn to watch good
Netflix shows but no matter where I go I
like to safeguard my online activity
nordvpn's state-of-the-art encryption
protects you from third parties who want
to watch what you're doing online it
also protects you from hackers malware
and malicious people who might want to
track your online activity with their
incredibly fast coverage some vpns are
so slow nordvpn is a simple way to
guarantee your privacy and keep you safe
online super easy to start using and it
protects you from anyone knowing what
websites you've been visiting and I
think given the political atmosphere
right now it's worth doing just in case
the government gets weird who knows grab
your exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com
tmpp to get a huge discount off your
nordvpn plan plus four months for free
it's completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee so you can
go there see how fast it is forget
you're using a VPN be protected sign up
for nordvpn and enjoy this episode
Rick Ross welcome to my podcast thank
you it's nice to be here Michaela yeah
this should be a fun conversation I
decided to have you on because
apparently you're at cult expert so
before we get started can you give a
brief background about
what it is you do and who you are okay I
started my work in 1982. I am the
founder and executive director of The
Cult Education Institute which is a an
educational non-profit with a huge
Library Online about destructive groups
called Cults and other controversial
groups uh you can find it at
culteducation.com I also do
interventions to help people leave Cults
and I've done over 500 across the United
States and internationally and I testify
as a court expert witness in cases
involving controversial groups such as
groups that have been called Cults I've
been qualified and testified in 11
States including United States Federal
Court wow okay so why did you decide to
spend your life doing this looking into
Cults and understanding them I well as
started Michaela as a personal thing a
weird group infiltrated a nursing home
where my grandmother lived and they were
targeting the Elder and quite frankly it
kind of pissed me off and so I wanted to
protect my grandmother I wanted to
protect the other people there and then
I guess I became an anti-cult activist
slash Community organizer and then I was
on one committee after another committee
and then I worked for a social service
agency and then started doing
interventions privately in the 80s and
so it grew out of a personal interest
because it affected my family and I
could see that it was a negative thing
and as I continued I realized how dark
and and very negative the world of
destructive cults uh is and and just how
terrible it can be for example Keith
renery the leader of this group called
Nexium that I that I uh exposed uh very
early on in uh around
2001-2002 renery is now serving 120
years in prison for uh for tax fraud for
sex trafficking for racketeering uh he
is the man that that created this kind
of sex cult where women were actually
physically branded with his initials
with a quadrant oh my gosh there were
many women that were tortured in this
way and so I helped Catherine Oxenberg
uh an actress whose daughter India
Oxenberg was in the group and then I
also helped many families and I helped
many people to leave Nexium uh Keith
Ranieri sued me for 14 18 years because
I published these papers by two doctors
a psychiatrist and a clinical
psychologist that were analyzing what
was wrong with these training seminars
that were under the umbrella of Nexium
that they were causing people to have
meltdowns be hospitalized and the
doctors explained why and when I
published those papers online at
culteducation.com
Keith renery sued me and that lawsuit
went on for 14 years and was dismissed
shortly before his arrest I also wrote
the book Cults inside out which is the
first book about cults to include Keith
rainieri and Nexium wow okay okay well I
have I have a bunch of questions I think
let's start at the beginning here what's
the difference between a cult and and a
religion well a religion does not have
typically an absolute totalitarian
leader here that becomes the defining
element and driving force of the group
and that leader really becomes an object
of worship so what you have typically is
a Founder who has absolute power there
are no checks and balances whatever he
says is right is right whatever he says
is wrong is wrong and then the leader uh
uses identifiable thought reform and
influence techniques to coercively you
know break people down change the way
they think and then lock them in in a
kind of group environment that the
leader controls and then finally if it's
going to be called a destructive cult uh
you you would look to see how is the
group hurting people because if the
group is perhaps a benign call and they
don't hurt anyone they have a leader
they have a mindset but they're not
really hurting anyone then really it's
not something that would draw my
attention so what I'm looking for is are
they hurting people and that could that
varies by degree from group to group uh
Nexium Keith rainieri would be a very
extreme example of destructive Behavior
but there are many groups that they just
want your money they want free Labor uh
and then it can escalate to sexual
exploitation and abuse physical abuse
and criminality uh for example the cult
om shinrikio in Japan where the leader
shoka Sahara in 1995 ordered his people
to release poison sarin gas in the Tokyo
subway system thousands of people were
hospitalized many people died because of
what he did and so he ended up being
executed other members of the group were
in prison and this is an example of
probably on a one to ten one being you
know a cranky but least destructive cult
and then 10 being the worst I think
asahara would be a 10.
wow okay so you've kind of been in a
battle for when did you start doing this
40 years ago
so I've been doing my work for 40 years
sounds like a somewhat stressful way to
live yeah I've been under the protection
of the justice department uh Homeland
Security and the FBI because of threats
on my life Keith rainieri who I
mentioned had me under surveillance uh
penetrated my private banking records
and phone records and you know just
harassed me for more than a decade and
there have been other groups uh that
also have sued me and harassed me and uh
stalked me and threatened my life over
the years when I testified against
rhaenery in federal court I was under
the protection of the Homeland Security
Department so it you know it's it can be
dangerous it can be stressful but I
think uh I can't think of anything that
I've done in my life that is not is
equally rewarding as seeing people who
have been victimized by Cults for read
and seeing just horrible I I would say
evil cult leaders put away
and and Keith rainieri is now in a
lockdown uh kind of isolated protective
custody place where sex criminals go and
he raped children he raped a 12 year old
he raped a 14 year old and so recently
another sex offender who didn't rape
children uh punched him out beat him up
and he complained about it but even in
prison there's a kind of code and
somebody who rapes children they're at
the very bottom and that's where Keith
Renee is now and I I'm happy to say I
helped to put in that have you seen an
overlap in personality between all these
cult leaders yeah absolutely I mean I
remember one time talking to the
psychologist and cult expert Margaret
Singer who really was probably the
leading cult expert of the 20th century
and I asked her I had dealt with a cult
leader by the name of David koresh who
was the leader of a group called The
Waco Davidians and I'd help people leave
the Davidians help the number of
families I was working with the batf and
the FBI and doing analysis for CBS News
and someone said that they could
deprogram
uh David korash and I said how can you
deprogram him he he's not uh uh he's not
programmed in the first place he's a
psychopath and that person said to me
well I don't think he's a psychopath and
so I asked Margaret Singer what do you
think and she said Rick they're all
Psychopaths and I think the the uh the
basic threshold requirements to be a
cult leader is number one be at least a
sociopath with no sense of right or
wrong no conscience you don't care who
you hurt what a cult leader cares about
is what's in it for me what's good for
me is good and what's bad for me is bad
and they have no innate kind of morals
or ethics or anything like that and then
typically they're just uh intensely
narcissistic I would describe them as
malignant narcissists very extreme they
have little if any empathy they seem to
only have sympathy for themselves and uh
they're they're very uh
pathological in their pattern of lying
and misrepresenting themselves so I've
met a number of cult leaders over the
years you know I've testified against
them in court I've met them face to face
and uh for example Keith reneri and to
me they they're all the same they're
almost all the same and I feel like I'm
meeting the same person with a different
skin suit
over and over again I mean because they
just they behave the same so these
aren't people that maybe start thinking
that they want to change the world for
the better you think these are just bad
people to begin with or do they have
this grandiose idea that they're going
to improve things and it just devolves
into
chaos I think it's possible
for them to have good intentions though
it's been argued that that they usually
are born
pretty much bad some of them seem to be
hardwired that way reneri was harassing
little girls when he was 10 and he was
recognized as a predator
um Charlie Manson you know the Manson
family the Tate Le Bianca murders uh in
the in 1970 1969 that family was active
and you know Manson was definitely a
psychopath but you could argue that
because of his very unhappy childhood
and the fact that he was raised
basically within juvenile facilities and
prisons that that he was he was
influenced to be bad but um there in my
opinion they are very often innately bad
uh there was a leader Charles Diedrich
who started a intentional community of
for drug rehabilitation called synonym
which was very popular in California in
in oh oh synonym would be going back to
the 80s and eventually Dietrich would be
prosecuted for criminal offenses and the
group would be taken down but I think
originally it seemed like there were
good intentions that is to get people
off drugs to get yeah live a sober clean
life but it just went off the rails
because in my experience when you don't
have checks and balances and
transparency in the hierarchical
structure of a group you know absolute
power
corrupts I mean people become corrupted
by not having anyone to answer to and I
think Diedrich got worse and worse until
he was arrested and I think that many
cult leaders seem to have started out
not so bad and and the situation
escalates uh Jim Jones would be another
other example Jim Jones was very popular
within a Democratic party circles he was
very good friends with Governor Jerry
Brown a state assemblyman Willie Brown
with Rosalind Carter visited San
Francisco she did a photo op with Jim
Jones he would later be responsible for
the murder of a thousand people
including over 200 children in what was
called the Jonestown murder suicide uh
he but at one time he was the head of a
very big church in the Bay Area and they
had a branch in LA and there were
thousands and thousands of people that
thought he was he was fantastic he was a
liberal mover and Shaker who basically
created
programs to feed the elderly drug
rehabilitation uh the church was very
multi-racial Multicultural and he was
seen as kind of an icon of change in the
70s but in 1978 he ended up with a
thousand of his die-hard followers in
English-speaking Guyana and after he
murdered a United States Congressman
that came to investigate what was going
on in that Community which was isolated
in the jungle where where Jim Jones
controlled everything uh he reckoned
that the authorities were coming for him
they were and so they mixed what what
was referred to as Kool-Aid with poison
Cyanide and uh phenobarbital and
sleeping you know pills and the end
result was a thousand people dead and
Jim Jones as well and that's where we
get the phrase oh you drank the Kool-Aid
that's an allusion to Jonestown uh
though the Kool-Aid company wants us to
know it really wasn't cool it was it was
Flavor Aid it wasn't their Kool-Aid it
was a different one but uh that was a
big shocker for everybody in 78 I think
and people said who are these Cults what
are they doing a thousand people are
dead 200 children their bodies are being
moved out of Guyana what is this how
could they be there where did they come
come from they're Americans what what
are they doing in a compound in the
middle of the Jungle and so that was the
beginning of uh cult awareness and in my
book Cults inside out I really get into
that history and I show the uh evolving
of of you know Cults beginning in the
70s too today is this something that was
like were Cults very I guess not popular
but were there were there more Cults in
the 70s than there are now is this
something that was more frequent back
then or did people just find out about
them then
um Michaela it's a growth industry okay
okay social media and we have PayPal and
we have ways that people can be
recruited online and then extracted
money from them and so on there are all
kinds of Cults that proliferate online
uh I'll give you just one example uh
there's a group called carbon nation and
this this is led by an African-American
by the name of eligio Bishop he also
went by uh what what he Nature Boy was
at one time his nickname and so he would
recruit on Facebook on Twitter on social
media and then he rented an Airbnb
online in Costa Rica and some people
would give him money online and then
some people were pulled into the Airbnb
and it became a little cult compound the
Costa Ricans kicked him out the
panamanians later kicked him out the
Mexicans kicked him out he ended up back
in Atlanta where he was from and he's
now in jail facing charges of uh sexual
abuse and and you know criminal
exploitation of people in the group but
the group wasn't that big there were
maybe 30 40 people in the community at
the at the most uh and he could make
money and pay for the Airbnb D and
everything online and so you have groups
that are streaming online that there are
certain leaders that may even have
hundreds of thousands of followers
online
um there's a Woman by the name of Teal
Swan who's quite popular she's been
called a cult leader uh she would say
I'm not I'm just uh holding forth online
and she has hundreds of thousands of
people who follow her online and these
people become very wealthy and then they
extract some people from their online
following to become their Inner Circle
or Community Teal Swan has that uh Dr
Phil and I at one point exposed a Woman
by the name of Amy Carlson and she
headed a group called love has won and
you may have read about her she probably
had no more than 30 or 40 followers but
at the time of her death she had a half
a million in cash about an million in
real estate paid for and people were
vying for who's going to control the
assets of this group and they couldn't
accept Amy Carlson's death they called
her mother God so they took the body and
they decorated it with glitter and
lights and they basically worshiped it
until the authorities knocked down the
door and and arrested people for
essentially violating a dead body wow
okay so I've got a few questions then
what's the average type of person that
ends up in a cult is there an overlap
there there is a kind of narrative
thread that you could pull through a lot
of people but it could be anybody they
could be any race any socio-economic
level that could be rich they could be
poor they could be young they could be
old they could be highly educated or
uneducated uh but what I've seen if I
were gonna pull a consistent thread
through many of the cases that I've
dealt with it would be somebody who's
not happy at a particular point in their
life and they're feeling like I'm just
really unhappy with my life I'm
depressed and at that point they have
the bad luck that someone they know
could be a family member friend
co-worker they approach them and say hey
you want to come to this meeting you
want to go play volleyball with these
friends of mine I mean it could be very
innocuous it could seem very innocent
because the group is not going to tell
you what their agenda is or does close
anything I might put you off so a lot of
it's about deceptive Recruitment and
just flat out lying some of these groups
have multiple names you don't even know
who you're being recruited by you find
out later oh it's that cult that I read
about but now they're using a new front
organizational name that I didn't know
about so many of the people that I work
with are just amazing people really
smart
for example not long ago I was working
with a young woman who had recently
graduated with honors from Harvard
University
uh I also work with a young man who was
attending Penn the University of
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia on full
scholarship graduated from his classes
of valedictorian went on to MIT and is
now a civil engineer but at one point he
was lured into a cult on the campus of
Penn a lot of these groups do recruit on
college campuses because I'd say their
main target group is 18 to 26. but five
of the people that I have worked with
are medic we're our medical doctors I I
helped to deprogram and bring out of a
cult an orthopedic surgeon an
anesthesiologist a gastrointestinal
specialist these people were not dumb
they weren't illiterate they were
sophisticated well-educated people so I
think if we think that we're not
vulnerable
we're not we're not really being honest
with ourselves anyone can be had given
the right set of circumstances and
timing and and that's why I think it's
so important to be aware that these
groups exist so that you know what to
look for and you can be prepared and if
the group approaches you you can say hey
you know what you seem kind of weird you
seem like some kind of cult group and
you you do your due diligence and you
drill down and find out more and you
realize hey this is a cult Okay so
I guess we could start with how do
people identify when it's occult what
are the signs well you go to the meeting
and you see a big portrait of the leader
on the wall that's that's a real real
red flag and everybody is talking over
and over again about how great the
leader is and and the leader says this
and the leader says that and you realize
that the leader is what it's all about
and that they worship the leader and
that the leader is the core defining
element of the group and then you
realize that everyone
uh only views the leader through a
positive lens they're not critical no
one ever disagrees with the leader and
you also realize that there's no
accountability in the organization for
example
um a democratically elected board
uh Financial transparency through
published budgets distributed to all
contributors things like that you know
you go to guidestar you know uh or or
another website online and you find out
boy this is kind of shady they're not
really showing me where the money goes
and you you feel like there's no
legitimate reason to leave and that
anybody who leaves is characterized in a
negative light uh and and you also
recognize that people are becoming
isolated socially isolated and they're
kind of cocooning in this group and
they're not really uh in touch with
maybe their family uh their old friends
things like that and
um and when you begin to see these
warning signs over and over again you
begin to put together a picture of a
very authoritarian group everything is
black and white nothing in Shades of
Gray and people are just agreeing cons
instantly with whatever is said and you
might be there thinking God you know
they just said something that's really
weird why is everybody like nodding
their head what is this a bunch of head
Bobbers or what you know I mean is
anybody thinking here and so the group
kind of created a environment where
everything the leader says is reinforced
and nothing is ever questioned
okay that sounds pretty stereotypical
but that that sounds good you spoke a
bit about thought reform and influence
techniques could you describe what kind
of influence techniques cult leaders use
um I I write about this on a chapter in
my book called cult brainwashing and
probably the the seminal book on
influence techniques is the book
influenced by the uh Professor uh from
ASU Robert cialdini and I'll give you a
few of them one would be liking liking
we're more we're more apt to go along
with somebody that we like than somebody
we don't like which is the key to
celebrity endorsements I'm gonna buy
that car because uh that athlete or That
Celebrity is pitching it so that's why
they have celebrities do that is because
if you like that celebrity it will
influence you you buy the product so in
a cult you you experience what's called
like love bombing which means you get
into the group and this is another
warning sign and everybody's just loving
on you they're all just going oh oh wow
it's so great to meet you you're oh wow
you know uh we were you know they're
just saying a lot of effusive praising
things and it's because they want you to
like them and they want you to feel kind
of reluctant to to not embrace them
because they are so nice
so the principle is liking another one
would be social proof which is a big one
so you look around you to see what other
people are doing and then you determine
what you're going to do when you're at
the airport going into lines going
through uh TSA or whatever you're
looking are they taking off their shoes
or what you know I mean do I need to
take off my shoes so that is what we
call social proof so if a group can
cocoon you in in a uh what I would call
a false social proof where everything is
really controlled and you're getting
this feedback that everything is normal
even though it's not you feel that your
doubts your misgivings are misplaced and
so you kind of go well nobody else is
acting like this is bad so I'll act like
it's okay as well so social proof would
be another one and another one would be
Authority so you're more likely to be
compliant with someone who represents
Authority than someone who doesn't so if
a uniformed police officer approaches
you and says uh let's I want to talk to
you about the situation here you're
going to be more attentive than it's
some guy in cutoffs and a t-shirt you
know so if the group projects Authority
and they may do that by for example in
invoking God invoking the Bible saying
everything I say to you is in this book
the Bible when in reality they're
they're very likely twisting scriptures
out of context for their own purposes
but but if they can invoke the authority
of the Bible that's a big one in the U.S
and and Western Europe so you say I I'm
not speaking for myself but Jesus said
the Bible says you know Moses said so
then you're gonna kind of thinking well
I have to go along with this because of
the authority of scripture because of
who they are quoting and so on and that
could be manipulated in many different
ways so before I jumped on the podcast I
was doing a bit of reading and I looked
up the most popular cults in America
right now and it looked like a huge
percentage of them like maybe 80 percent
had something to do with like somebody's
version of the Bible
which shocked me that a lot of them uh
were considered Cults so that was
interesting I didn't know that are Cults
more prevalent in America or is this
something that really occurs worldwide
it occurs worldwide
um my book was translated into Chinese
and Italian and I've lectured abroad as
well as across the U.S uh and and really
uh in the U.S though because of the
First Amendment separation of church and
state and because of the relative ease
in which a group can say look we're a
religious group give us 501c3 non-profit
religious status which which really
gives them kind of almost a license to
steal at times because they don't have
to pay taxes they don't pay property
taxes and and religious organizations in
our history in the U.S are given more
protection than let's say another
non-profit like an educational
non-profit so the religious uh uh cult
or or some type of spiritually based
cult will say well look you know we're
religion and if you criticize anything
our leader does if you criticize what
we're doing even if it's former members
that are saying they were ripped off or
they were hurt they were exploited
that's persecution
so you better be careful because we're
protected by the First Amendment so I
think a lot of groups come from overseas
quite a few and they set up shop or they
set up a branch in the U.S because this
is where they like to have their money
this is where they might make some
Investments uh because of the protection
that our country affords uh people
through the first amendment separation
of church and state do you know what the
cult is around currently that has the
most members is or in the past the
largest cult I would say one of the
largest groups that was called a cult
would be a group called The
International Church of Christ which was
founded by a guy by the name of Kip
McKean in fact Kip is still out there
doing his thing but the group has fallen
on kind of hard times but at their Peak
they went from 12 members in 1978 to
about I would say about 250
000. by 1998 and then a number of
scandals occurred and Kip McKean kind of
fell from Grace uh it was a bible-based
group and it was a break off from the
Independent Churches of Christ though
the first people to blow the whistle on
Kip McCain was in fact the independent
Churches of Christ they said this guy is
not good he used to kind of be with us
and he broke away and they were very
critical of him and he is still out
there I mean he's like now what is Kip
he must be in his 70s and he's still
preaching he's he's probably down to
maybe he's just got maybe 5 000 or less
actual followers at this point and of
course people often think that
Scientology which has been called a cult
is uh really big and the scientologists
will always say oh we have millions we
have millions probably based on what I
know they probably have less than 50 000
members globally oh and that they've
been kind of losing
members over a period of time uh the
founder L Ron Hubbard died in 1986 and
his successor was his former secretary a
man by the name of David miscavige whose
best buddies with Tom Cruise
uh in fact he was Tom Cruise's best man
when Tom Cruise married Katie Holmes uh
I don't I don't think he I don't think
he was at the divorce settlement though
but any anyway David miskevige is now
the absolute leader of Scientology and
what I think is significant about
scientology is how much money they have
uh between their real estate and their
and their cash it's been estimated that
Scientology is now worth more than three
billion dollars
and it's been said by some Inner Circle
people that left that they have a
billion just in cash
and so if you go to Clearwater Florida
they own a chunk of downtown if you go
to Hollywood in Los Angeles you're going
to see a lot of buildings controlled by
Scientology so their real estate
portfolio is awesome I mean it's a very
very full of these properties that they
don't pay taxes on by and large because
they get religious non-profit status is
the government after these people like
mad no you know I think it's it boils
down to you you if they're doing weird
things if they're indoctrinating people
and people are believing in science
fiction stories or whatever which is the
case with Scientology it's just an issue
of criminality you know so so for
example Danny Masterson uh you know from
That 70s Show he's facing rape charges
and the allegations are that he took
advantage of scientologists women and
that because they were all in
Scientology they were essentially kept
from uh speaking out they were you know
they they were dealt with internally by
Scientology and that Danny Masterson got
away with things because he was you know
a Scientology celebrity and now
Masterson is facing trial in in the
coming months for what he did so if a
group doesn't do something criminal if
they don't actually break the law then
the authorities are not going to go
after them so it could be tax fraud it
could be money laundering it could be
sex trafficking it could be racketeering
in some way or it could be something
like for example violation of copyright
uh there was one leader his name was
Keith Hamm and he built a huge temple in
Virginia and it was like the Krishna
Temple The Hare krishnas and ham also
liked to sell counterfeit Disney
paraphernalia and one of the things that
he was busted on was counterfeit
counterfeiting Goods later it was he
also was involved in a murder conspiracy
because there were people that were
leaving the Hare Krishna movement that
were very critical of this guy and he
wanted them taken out and so there were
people that were killed so if the cult
doesn't do anything illegal if all they
do is believe in weird stuff and uh that
you can't really you know you can't
prosecute them for that and sadly if
they break up marriages they break up
families they isolate people they
compromise their education their career
none of that is Criminal I mean because
the cult will just say well you know
this is what we uh we all shared this
and this person made this choice on
their own but I would argue that they
were under undue influence and that
that's why they made choices that were
not in their best interest what does
cult deprogramming look like oh uh it
looks like a surprise to start off yeah
because you don't like send somebody an
invitation and say uh gee you know would
you please attend this uh deprogramming
because they're going to they're going
to immediately text
their their leader their Associates in
the group or they're going to email them
or call them and they're going to say
what should I do and they're going to
tell them no way so first of all it's
like a drug or alcohol intervention it's
a total surprise and so the person
typically they they they're with their
family for a visit they're on vacation
uh and the F or the family may come to
their home it could be the adult
children uh having an intervention for
their parents it could be the parents
more typically doing an intervention
with regarding an adult child
uh so or it could be a spouse so you
start off it's a surprise the person who
is the focus of the intervention is
probably kind of pissed and they're
saying you know why are you doing this
you you know you like blindsided me so
you have to kind of work through that
and say look we're here because your
family's very worried about you they're
concerned about you and then you begin
this discussion with the family or the
loved ones present and you're talking
really about
four things during the Intervention
number one defining what is a
destructive cult or a destructive
authoritarian group what are its core
elements does it match up with the group
you're involved in number two what is
coercive persuasion what are these
influence techniques that you think uh
have been used to gain undue influence
over me and then you discuss all of the
particulars the criteria of what
constitutes coercive persuasion or
thought reform and then third
why is my family worried about me and so
the family is going to say well you know
you're not taking your insulin because
you think the group can cure your
diabetes I've been involved in three
interventions like that where people
almost died uh because they believed
that the group had a cure for diabetes
which they did not and they they were in
and out of the hospital trying to cure
so so that would be uh one concern of
the family their physical well-being
their health or it could be their
financial well-being that they're giving
everything to the group or that they're
not not paying attention to their
children that they're neglecting their
family uh that they're becoming
increasingly isolated and so for so the
family is now saying this is why we're
here this is why we brought this guy
Rick to come and sit with us and talk
about this stuff and then the next thing
would be what is it that the group is
hiding from you is the group hiding
anything from you do you know everything
about this group so then comes out the
research did you know that the leader uh
was arrested for spousal abuse did you
know the leader has a secret getaway
that a million dollars was the price tag
uh did you know that the leader is
basically enriching himself and his
family from the money from the group
which is supposed to be a charitable
non-profit you know you you want to
bring out all that and then the person
ultimately is going to make their own
choice uh the intervention might take
three days
so you're gonna agree to meet again the
next day the next day you might talk for
five six eight hours a day with the
family and uh and the person that's
involved and then ultimately though it's
up to them do they want to leave the
group do they want to take a break do
they just want to say forget it I'm
going back about seven uh out of ten
people that I sit down with will decide
to take a break or leave the group at
the end
but about 30 percent will say I'm
leaving in the first day because I don't
like what you're talking about I don't
like it and that is their choice
so you basically go in there and try and
untangle people from a narrative yeah
well does this narrative make more sense
and then they have to think about it if
they're willing to I think I think what
you're doing is you are explaining to
them
how they got to where they're at that
they've become basically upon for the
group in most situations yeah and they
have subordinated their value judgments
their thinking to the leaders in the
group so to the extent that that it's
negatively impacting their life so what
you want to do is rewind the entire
recruitment process the indoctrination
process and say how did you get from
where you were you were an independent
functioning person to where you are now
where you're so dependent upon the group
uh and the leader to make decisions for
you I mean uh for example what give me
an example of something that you
disagree with the group about
I mean typically people can say oh I
don't like uh this about my church or I
don't like this about the club that I'm
in or the fraternity or sorority that
I'm in I think that person's a jerk this
is kind of ridiculous that they do you
know and I'm not up for that but cult
members are more like locked in and they
can't think of anything significant that
they disagree with the group about so
you want to ask them how did you get
here let's look at the recruitment
process that brought you through let's
look at the indoctrination process that
nailed you down
and were you tricked and kind of Trapped
in this group or do you think that the
group was fully transparent and honest
with you so what you're really doing is
rewinding that process so that they can
uh slow motion it and and freeze it at
different points and examine it and then
decide is this what I really signed up
for I mean is it I in my experience most
people that are in Cults if they knew
what they were getting involved in from
the beginning
they would not have gotten involved I
mean if Scientology had had said to Tom
Cruise in the very beginning what they
fully believed you know regarding uh
their Origins you know which is a
science fiction story written by L Ron
Hubbard about a a Galactic Overlord
named Xenu who sent uh overpopulated
beings to this planet and then they were
they were killed and their their uh
Spirits are still residing in in our
environment and they attach themselves
to you and they would say Michaela you
have body fatens on you and the only
technology that can get those BTS off is
Scientology if they had told that to Tom
Cruise from day one when Mimi Rogers his
girlfriend then wife kind of brought him
into Scientology I think he would have
said God you guys have got a screw loose
I'm not I'm not interested in that
sci-fi stuff but they came to him and
they said look you've got dyslexia we
have study technology we're
self-improvement uh organization uh
we're here to help you realize your
potential and they painted a different
picture now he's pushing 60 he's three
for three three marriage just three
divorces and I would argue that every
one of them was a direct result of
Scientology
Mimi Rogers her parents left she was
raised in Scientology and she wanted to
continue with them because
scientologists routinely disconnect or
cut off a family member who leaves
Scientology they're labeled what
Scientology calls a suppressive person
an SP and so Mimi Rogers I think though
she's never really talked publicly about
this in any depth that she wanted to
continue to be part of her family and
her parents and so she left Scientology
and that made her an SP or at a bare
minimum what Scientology would call
potential trouble Source a pts so Tom
Cruise divorces her he marries Nicole
Kidman Nicole Kidman for a while I think
he really loved her and she really loved
him and she tried to kind of wean him
off of Scientology and it backfired and
Scientology sent in one of their
enforcers a guy named Marty Rathbun who
basically broke up that marriage and uh
and and it was about scientology and
then Katie Holmes I think really loved
Tom Cruise and I think he really loved
her I believe him when he was jumping on
the couch and saying at Oprah's show and
saying I love this woman I think he
really did and they had a beautiful
child that he hasn't seen for years his
daughter Serena
and it it why because Katie Holmes I
would say did not want to have her
daughter raised in Scientology and she
did not want to be in Scientology so
here's this guy that's gone through
decades with Scientology three divorces
he's a really smart guy I mean look at
his career amazing rare So how do you
figure it I I figure it that he was in
my opinion tricked and trapped in
Scientology and that he can't imagine a
life outside of Scientology though now
he doesn't talk about it very much yeah
because he doesn't want to
um put a negative uh you know element in
his rollout of his movie projects and I
think that's smart but um he's really
been damaged I think in my opinion by
Scientology yeah I I'd say say so his
credibility for sure
have you dealt with a lot of people who
were trapped in Cults so when you did an
intervention they said okay you're right
but I can't leave because I don't know
they're blackmailing me or something
like that I dealt with a really sad
situation once with a man who had left
the mainstream Mormon church and he had
become a member of a polygamist uh cult
the one that we all have heard about the
flds led by Warren Jeffs who's now in
prison for molesting and raping children
uh so this man became involved he was uh
deeply involved he had four wives uh by
the time I met him but he was becoming
very disillusioned as many of the people
in the flds have have become uh and many
have left uh this uh cult at one time
controlled the towns of Hilldale Utah
and Colorado City Arizona the police
force city government schools everything
it was like a cult town and so this man
became disillusioned but he has all
these children he has four wives I met
with him I talked with them because his
sister who was a mainstream Mormon felt
sorry for him he was visiting with her
and he was very sad and she said why
don't you talk to this guy who knows
about groups like this and maybe you can
see a way to resolve this and I would
love for you to leave and and come back
into the fold with our family which
you've been isolated from from for years
and at the end you could see that there
was just no way
because he had all these wives all these
kids I don't know how many kids he had
probably a 15 20. and it's a family unit
that he built over a period of decades
and he could not see walking away from
that and that that keeps a lot of cult
members anchored and and I write about
that in my book it's I would call it
exit costs what are the exit costs yeah
of leaving the group are you going to
lose your job are you going to lose your
family are are you going to feel that
after years of devotion that you have
nowhere really to go with your life that
maybe you're too old you've been in a
group for a really long time I once
worked with a man who joined Scientology
when he was 22.
and he left when he was almost 50. and
the family did an intervention he had
been in Scientology for 27 years
from the age of 22 to 49. and I write
about him in my book and he had a
terrible time coming out of Scientology
he did and the way that I think he could
do that was because his wife wasn't
really that involved she she and he
loved her and they'd been married many
years he had two adult children going to
college and they weren't really involved
so he had a family to be with that loved
him but all of his friends were
scientologists every single one of them
practically and for him to leave that
kind of subculture and start over again
it was tough but he did he managed to do
it but it that is one of the reasons
that people stay they just can't imagine
a life after Decades of being in a group
and peop some people will leave a group
called a cult very relatively soon like
in the first year to five years but
there are many people who stay for 10
years 15 years 20 years
for example Allison Mack the actress
that was in Smallville you know that
series about Superman growing up you
know she had a great career she was very
well liked by many people in the
entertainment industry and she ended up
with Keith renery and Nexium
for I guess 20 years pretty much and and
and by the time it was over she had lost
most of her money her career her
reputation and as we speak she's in
prison she's going to be serving out a
three and a half year prison term and
she sacrificed it all and uh very very
sad very sad that that that happened to
her but she was involved in this
torturing of women
uh she was directly and physically
involved and so they had to send her to
prison uh but I think if she were
talking to you right now she'd probably
say she has some serious regrets about
how long she stayed in Nexium is Nexium
the most brutal cult that you've studied
no I think the Waco Davidians that was a
pretty brutal group I mean David koresh
raped children uh some of them bore him
children when they were children uh the
one girl I met he raped when she was 10
uh the group was heavily armed they were
militaristic uh they were violent uh I
think that was a really bad group I
think that I'm shinrikio uh shoko
asahara who had members of his group
that were physicists that were working
on weapons of mass destruction they were
testing the poison gas on the Tokyo
subway system as a Prelude they were
also hoping to to build a nuclear device
I think shoko asaharanam shinrika were a
terrible group and uh there have been oh
uh various groups like Jim Jones
Jonestown the 1000 people that died
there definitely worse than Nexium there
was a group in Africa movement for the
restoration of the Ten Commandments led
by a man by the name of Joseph kibwitare
and that group kibutary predicted the
end of the world in the year 2000 and
when it didn't happen and people were
starting to want to leave and rejoin
their families this was going on in
Uganda
Terry just started killing them by the
time he was done there were 750 bodies
recovered that was a really bad group
and I don't know if you remember
Heaven's Gate that was a small group led
by a man named Marshall Applewhite 39
people were found found dead including
Apple White in a mansion they leased
between Los Angeles and San Diego in the
general area of La Jolla that was in
1995 and then there was also a group in
Europe called the solar Temple and that
group uh ended in mass murder suicide
about 80 90 people died along with their
leader Luke cheray who was from Canada
and they ended up in in Chalets in
Switzerland and France where where they
died in deliberately set fires
so there have been just many many groups
like this and and I would want to point
out also groups that do not believe in
medical care there are a number of
groups in the United States uh for
example General Assembly Church of the
firstborn
um and uh Christ followers or excuse me
followers of Christ that do not believe
in any kind of medical care so members
in those groups routinely die many of
them children and only recently have the
courts begin to strike down religious uh
exemptions for parents who don't want to
take their children to a doctor so a
number of them have been prosecuted
they've been sentenced to prison and
children have been saved by court order
but many children have died there was
one group Faith Assembly led by Hobart
Freeman in Indiana where there just were
so many children that died in that group
because they they could have been taken
to a doctor and about 80 percent of them
could have survived I mean only a small
percentage were incurable it could be
something as simple as the use of
antibiotics
so children died they died in pain from
these uh Faith healing groups is what
they're often called and of course uh
there are quite a few of them in the
United States and then of course we have
the polygamous communities and the abuse
of children uh in those communities
there are about fifty thousand people in
North America that are involved in
polygamist groups this is wild I think
the Cults that I'd heard of I'd heard of
Jonestown right that's what that was
called I'd heard of that
um and Scientology of course what about
the Moonies
can you describe who they were and are
they still around they are still around
uh Reverend Moon started what back in
the 50s the 60s and he created what was
called the unification Church
and he built it originally in South
Korea and then he started building
branches in Japan in North America and
they were known as the Moonies because
they worshiped Reverend Moon as the
Messiah Reverend Moon would teach them
that he alone uh would redeem the world
and that basically Jesus had flunked and
that he was going to fulfill what needed
to be done and they would recruit young
people on college campuses and then they
would persuade them to go to these
Retreats these camps that were scattered
around the United States where they
would be intensely indoctrinated and
isolated for periods of weeks many
people would call this being brainwashed
and then the Moonies would go on the
streets this happened in the 70s and the
80s and they would just be
oftentimes deceptively
Shilling for donations they would give
different different names they would not
identify themselves correctly and they
even fake being disabled to get money
and so Reverend moon at one point had
thousands of people in the United States
hitting the streets daily Shilling for
him and the average Mooney would make
about 200 bucks a day and they'd bring
it back to Reverend moon on that basis
he built a financial Empire that is now
valued at over one billion dollars uh
Reverend Moon died at the age of I think
92 a few years back his family now runs
the group at one point they own
one-third of the American fishing fleet
and they they were accountable for I
think as much as 50 percent at one point
of the wholesale Sushi market so in big
cities like New York and Chicago the
unification Church would pretty much
control roll the sushi business and
Reverend moon created a real estate
Empire the family still controls the New
Yorker Hotel in Manhattan and they
bought land in South America their
Mansions I mean it was a very successful
group and most recently when you read in
the news about the prime minister of
Japan
Abby who they just buried him in a state
funeral he was the Prime Minister of
Japan he was assassinated by a young man
uh 41 years old who was unhappy with Abe
because of his connection to Reverend
moon and the unification Church what the
young man's mother in Japan was built
out of 750 000 and it decimated the
family bankrupted them and the young man
suffered his family suffered and he and
he blamed Abe because Abe was influenced
by the unification church he he he would
you know go along with things help them
in different ways uh he would be a
speaker at some of their activities and
so uh so the man made a gun and shot the
former prime minister of Japan who was
recently buried and it really caused all
the Japanese is to come forward that
were hurt by the unification Church many
of them and they would say yes this
happened to me and different cult
experts in Japan would also come forward
and say yeah this is really a problem
and the group is still very much alive
and well in Japan and they have quite a
following in the U.S wow okay I didn't
realize they were still around what's
your view on Q Anon
is that a cult I think of it as a cult
but it's a very unusual cult
um the the leader is anonymous so who is
q is Q an individual is q a collective
we don't know I don't think Q is
actually a high-ranking person uh in the
established uh
you know intelligence Community as as
portrayed and then there are factions
within the Q Anon uh movement that are
classic Cults there's one woman she
calls herself the queen of Canada and
she leads a faction of Q Anon people and
she's an object of worship and there was
another man uh with a group of followers
not long ago in Dallas Texas who also is
a charismatic leader of a faction and
they were waiting for JFK to make
himself uh JFK Jr I think to make
himself known in Dallas and of course
nothing happened but in a sense the Q
Anon group is classic because they
they're very they're kind of cocooned
online and they're very kind of socially
isolated and no matter how many times
Q's predictions fail they just hang in
there and that's what's called cognitive
dissonance in destructive cult volts
that is if you believe something like I
believe what Q told me and then it
doesn't happen and then the group spins
it they say well it didn't happen
because of this that and the other and
then you being cocooned online and all
of your social interactions are with
other Q Anon people to a large extent
whatever the spin is it's reinforced by
the group and so you then reconcile the
conflict between what you have been told
to believe and what actually occurs and
that's a very eerie kind of cult-like
feature of Q Anon is that there's kind
of an alternate reality going on with
those folks and no matter how many times
there are these failed predictions they
just keep hanging in there
do Cults always take money like if you
have a relative that you and they join
something and you're like is that person
in a cult it's kind of getting culty
Vibes over there can you identify it by
the Cults asking for money or are there
Cults that ask for something else well
they they typically want something I
mean because the leaders that I've dealt
with are are not a very
um anti-materialistic kind of folks yeah
they want a nice car they want this they
want that and they feel they're entitled
and they want all the members to help
them so it could be labor that the
leader makes money off of
groups that have lawn services made
services and the leader provides cheap
housing no health insurance very little
money and the leader then builds it out
by the hour for these services and makes
a very substantial profit so it could be
free labor it could could be just cash
I've seen leaders that have cheated
people out of Real Estate One
intervention I did with the so-called
psychic group led by this psychic woman
she was working with a doctor who by the
time the children of the doctor brought
me in she had given 650 000 that they
knew of
by by bank records to the leader so
typically yeah they're out to get
something they're out to enrich
themselves uh and of course there's a
cult-like aspect I think to multi-level
marketing
so that's when you sign up for something
like Amway or Herbalife or lulero or or
whatever and you probably are not going
to make much money and you're probably
maybe likely going to lose money and yet
you have you see this group of people
that are like a community and they're
all yeah yeah it's we're we're gonna
yeah the product you know and really
it's it's kind of a process of
indoctrination to believe in the dream
that the group proposes will be your
life you know you're going to be rich
like this distributor oh look at her
more money than God you know we just we
just bought her a pink Cadillac so the
group really is not so much selling a
product as their recruiting Distributors
who then buy the product and then also
pay up in a multi-level scheme and
there's a very small group of people at
the top that actually make a lot of
money and so how do you get people to do
that I would propose that in my opinion
you gain undue influence over them by
isolating them socially within your
community and you just hit them with
this false social proof and all of this
liking and authority and whatever and
the end result is they're they're they
become Deployable they become your pawn
and they lose money and that's how the
people at the top make money and I I
think that many people in multi-level
marketing seem like they're
they've been had they've been conned and
that the real currency of the
multi-level marketing scheme is how do I
gain undue influence over these people
so I can exploit them so they have
training seminars Community Gatherings
all kinds of things uh you know they're
they're uh they're online they're
they're getting together online and
they're following each other on Facebook
on Twitter on Tick Tock and they're
streaming I mean this is what's going on
with multi-level marketing right now and
so I think people get caught up in it
and that the currency of multi-level
marketing in my opinion is the the
technology of being able to break people
down and change the way they think so
that you can take advantage of them I
wonder if it also gives people a
community like lonely people right
people who are already isolated and
they're then they think oh there's this
group and they're my friends I'll help
them out and then even if there's a part
of you that knows you're being taken
advantage of well you have this group of
people and they look like they care for
you right I assume they get a lot of
isolated people involved in those kind
of schemes
it's sad that would be a vulnerability I
mean someone who really never fit in who
who is looking for a community
acceptance maybe they have family issues
where they they don't feel loved and
then these people love them or so they
think what I often tell people is ask
yourself this if you said I don't want
anything to do with this scheme this
group this leader would they still love
you and if they won't is that what what
kind of love is that I think that's
highly conditional love is that what you
really want because that's kind of fake
is that what you want and there are
people that will say you know I am so
lonely so depressed yes I I will take
that I remember one young woman telling
me that I I don't care about what what
you've told me I agree with what you
told me the group is a cult but it's the
first time I've ever felt accepted the
first time I've ever felt loved and and
I said well yeah but that's highly
conditional it's predicated on your
compliance with the group and obedience
to the leader and she said I don't care
I want to be with them they are my
family they are my community and this
was a very socially awkward young woman
who had never really had a boyfriend
never really had good friends and felt
always odd person out and this group
they loved on her big time and she was
willing to take that so but usually
people will say no if it's not genuine
if they really don't care about me
then I'm going to leave because I don't
need that kind of fake stuff I'd rather
go out and find something real yeah
have you seen any overlap recently in
affiliation with political parties and
cult-like behavior well I'm gonna tell
you that I think that the word cult is
being overly politicized so you've got
people on the
on the left
saying oh you know Donald Trump is a
cult leader he is not a cult leader he
is a elected president of the United
States who won an election and he was
president and he then went through a
process as president where he was
accountable to the courts he was
accountable to the United States
Congress the Senate they would confirm
his appointments this there were checks
and balances and Donald Trump did not
brainwash anybody the people that follow
him that believe in him they were
predisposed to to be in agreement with
him and he knew that when he came out
and he said do you care about these
issues and he would tick them off you
know
immigration uh you know uh
China taking advantage of the United
States and trade or maybe you're not a
fan of NATO and you feel like our NATO
partners aren't paying enough or
whatever there was already an audience
for that there was already a group of
people very large group about 70 million
that said you know we really like what
this guy is saying and he is you know
he's charismatic he's he's a a very glib
speaker and he won them over on the flip
side I don't think you can say that uh
black lives matters or antifa are Cults
because I can identify that absolute
authoritarian leader that is the
defining element and driving force of
those groups that's an object of worship
so I think it's really important for
people on the right and on the left to
not uh
vilify and use the word cult as an
invective to tear down somebody because
it has very specific meaning and when I
testify as an expert in in court that's
always tested and I have to withstand
cross-examination
and so if I use the word destruct the
words destructive cult I'm going to be
very clear about why that group is
defined in that way or destructive
authoritarian group and I I don't think
that we should politicize the word and I
think it is being thrown around in a way
now that is not uh helpful and also I
would say it diminishes the genuine
suffering of cult victims because there
are people that have been brainwashed
that have been victimized and hurt very
badly by destructive Cults and I think
when we just glibly say oh you know this
guy's a cult leader uh the Maga people
are called the the uh Bernie Bros are
called uh Bernie Bernie Sanders is a
cult leader not really not like any cult
leader I've dealt with so I think we
should just chill chill it out there and
just kind of dial it down and not get
into that not point fingers and call
people a cult leader when they're not
that was a fantastic response how often
are cult leaders women versus men
because you've mentioned a number of
female cult leaders and I'm surprised I
think mostly I've heard about male call
leaders well it's mostly a man a man's
job it's mostly men but there have been
some very uh very famous uh cult leaders
that were women uh Elizabeth Claire
Prophet who led the group Church
Universal and triumphant she's now dead
but at one point she bought a ranch in
um uh I think it's in uh Wyoming Prime
primarily uh in in perhaps partially in
Montana from Malcolm Forbes the the
owner of Forbes Magazine and this was a
huge Ranch it was a huge compound and
she was a very formidable leader with
thousands of followers and millions and
millions of dollars and assets and at
one point she was predicting the end of
the world I think she her prediction was
around 1990 and so all these people
started moving into the compound and
they actually had uh underground bunkers
yeah waiting for the end and it didn't
happen surprise and so some of them left
and Elizabeth Claire Prophet eventually
died then there's a woman
in uh Spindale North Carolina her name
is Jane Whaley and she has presided over
a group called Word of Faith Fellowship
for many years
and uh she is has been called a cult
leader and um then there let me think
well we talked about Amy Carlson uh then
there was a a Woman by the name of Renee
julison
uh Renee's and her husband but she was
the real leader ran a group called
Victory Church in Grand Forks North
Dakota
and I did an Oprah Winfrey Show uh back
in 1992 exposing the group and bringing
out former members that actually had
tape recordings of Renee julison abusing
them on the phone and they were played
on Oprah and that was the beginning of
Victory Church which had hundreds of
members including three medical doctors
two of whom I worked with personally to
get them out of Victory Church but at
one point it was one of the biggest
churches in Grand Forks North Dakota and
it was a big story because Oprah Winfrey
ex exposed them in fact they threatened
her with a lawsuit they said we're we're
gonna sue you and and you can't play
those tapes they're confidential you
can't play them yeah said watch me and
she had her lawyers and she played them
on the air and boy they were very bad
for the leader Renee jewelerson she
ended up in Orlando Florida leading a
Bible study in a condominium condominium
Clubhouse again then her I think she
split from her husband and now they they
died in obscurity but at one point they
ruled over a very large Church in Grand
Forks
wow that's wild okay
that that's very interesting it's very
interesting how there are people
who kind of take off of Christianity
because you said after the cult kind of
fell apart she started leading a Bible
study group in Florida
it's interesting how you get people who
are
reading the Bible and then creating
their own churches
to take people's money well to not not
categorize everything as Christian based
there is a group called Summa Ching Hai
and you can find them online big group
and it's led by this woman who's
originally from Vietnam she now lives I
think most of the time in California
and she leads a group of thousands she
would say much more she has
um a television show she has podcasts
she streams and she's now 70. she's been
doing this for years and she owns the
largest largest chain of vegetarian
restaurants I think in the world there
are hundreds of them they're called
Loving Hut and she insists that she is
supreme Master Suma Ching Hai and that
she leads a group that is based kind of
on Buddhism and meditation and they're
intensely vegetarian vegans and that's a
group that really doesn't identify as
Christian led by a woman that that is
pretty big
hmm there it is Loving Hut is a chain of
vegan restaurants wow that's so weird
okay so if you if you start making
friends with people and someone is
calling them themselves supreme leader
that's a sign that that would be a
giveaway oh my group is just like a
regular group we get to together but the
name of our leader is supreme Master
though the members would say we have
Supreme master in us all
but then what I would say is yeah but
your leader uses it as a title so why
does she use it as a title and then I
will ask members uh I recently was
involved in an intervention I'll say can
you think of anyone else that would be
the equivalent of Suman Ching Hai as a
supreme master and it's like
no I can't you know because no one is
her equal on the planet yeah you know
and so people buy her jewelry they buy
uh paintings of her they typically might
have a large painting of her that they
paid a lot of money for hanging over
their living room couch you know and
that's a giveaway you know when people
are that caught up in the leader that
you know they're basically memorializing
the leader as an icon in their living
room but uh most groups are not that
obvious then would you have put just out
of curiosity would you have put somebody
like Stalin
in the group of cult leader in other
words there are a lot of Art
there's a lot of Stalin going around
I would say the leader of North Korea
Kim is a cult leader I would regret that
as a quasi-religious political call uh
that was started by his grandfather and
then his father and now him I would say
that Adolf Hitler
was definitely a cult leader they
weren't saying Heil Germany they were
saying Heil Hitler and they talked about
him as the father of the Fatherland the
fuhrer you know I was just watching uh
um a movie with Tom Cruise Valkyrie in
which it it it follows the attempted
assassination of Adolf Hitler by a man
by the name of stauffenberg and the way
that you see the people
uh you know worshiping you know photos
of Hitler portraits of Hitler the fear
the palpable fear that they have of him
as if he were Supernatural That's a cult
it's not just a political party it's a
cult and I would say Stalin yes I would
say so I would say also that Lenin
became a kind of charismatic cult leader
I mean look they've got his body
embalmed and and people go to Red Square
to see his body and to some extent you
know Chairman Mao was also uh it could
be called a political cult leader uh
they also have his body enshrined in
tenement Square
and then I think we could also oh we
could we could look at
um Ayatollah khumani who at one time was
I think worshiped in Iran in a way that
no other religious leader was his
equivalent I can remember when he died
uh they there were people literally
throwing themselves against the coffin
as they were going through the funeral
service so I think he became an object
of worship so I think at times a
political leader can be a cult leader
but um I think we must be very very
careful of how we use that because these
leaders that I've just described were
all dictators with absolute power they
had they they have no and had no
accountability and they were literally
an object of worship and I think if we
don't see that kind of extreme expressed
in a political group we shouldn't label
it a cult I think that's fair it's the
same thing as throwing people into the
Nazi category just casual or or
comparing everything to the Holocaust I
mean the Holocaust was millions of
people dying and over 2 million children
many of them infants that were murdered
so I think when we compare something to
the Holocaust we better choose our words
carefully and when we call somebody a
Nazi which was behind the Holocaust and
and the apparatus for genocide in
Germany and Europe we need to really
think about that because that's a very
harsh label can you let listeners know
who are interested in learning more what
they should read and where they should
go online to find you if you have a
presence online yes they can follow me
on Twitter rickallen Ross and they'll
see breaking stories about cults in my
Twitter feed
same thing with Facebook they can find
the institutional Facebook page for the
cult Education Institute there's a
YouTube channel they can find that
through culteducation.com there's a mess
Message Board a public message board
very big one attached to the cult
Education Institute that they can also
find through culteducation.com and then
if they really want to dig in and drill
into uh the subject of Cults uh they can
they can read my book Cults inside out
which is available in paperback they can
download it through Kindle on Amazon or
they can get the audible version and
it's a very comprehensive book that not
only has the history of modern Cults but
really delves into what makes them tick
with over a thousand research footnotes
and an 18-page bibliography awesome okay
thank you very much for coming on and
talking about all this thank you
Michaela
[Music]
thank you